[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm late and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're going to be exploring
the question did our careers just peak
we are fresh off of a tour a little mini
tour we went to st. Louis Columbus
Washington DC in Nashville and in
Nashville the venue was very special
because it was the Mother Church of
country music the Ryman Auditorium yeah
so I mean you just you just mentioned to
me and we we translated it into the
question of this episode you said that
the thought did cross your mind is this
is this the is this the peak of our
career so yeah yeah I think I think so
we want to we want to talk to you about
the whole tour
you know I'm certain we will reflect on
that specifically he e ek peak not did
our careers just like lean over and look
around a corner at us no yes that would
be PE K oh that's is what you meant yeah
oh you're talking about PE a K yes oh
you tell my P i qu e peak not that what
what do you mean by PE e K you don't you
just you're being humorous
I'm just doing some spelling humor okay
that's one of my favorite things to do
on a podcast the spelling humor goes
really well you know in the audio I mean
I always look for a chance to spell peak
p IQ three different ways yes lutein
that way okay if your interest is piqued
just a little grammar lesson is p IQ UD
it's not p EA ke D like it was the peak
of your interest and if I peek around a
corner and that piques your interest
then that may be a peak moment for you
right right yeah and you know what
spelling is important so so we kind of
want to go through a Spelling's
important it is put that on a t-shirt
listen I watch do you watch do you watch
your kids spell my oh it sounds quite
boring no like have you ever like gone
okay look over your shoulder and watch
your spell while they let write a paper
I've read their papers yeah you've never
been with them when you're in the
process of writing a paper now listen I
can relate to this because I've become
incredibly dependent on spellcheck yeah
but kids these days man like they got it
bad they I mean they could they stumble
over like the and it's all too corrected
for them
how else would you spell the th that's
also correct a th a qu he your kids
don't know a spell V that's thick man so
we're gonna step through a bunch of that
but um one of the things that we know
you know we don't we don't you don't
have a lot of time in each town we did
for those four dates over the course of
five days so it's pretty aggressive but
you do find these little pockets of time
to experience a little sliver of the of
the locale and one of the things that
we've noticed that was that was across
all of these cities it's I think it's
something that's sweeping the nation
sweeping maybe the world of course I
didn't see them in London or did I no I
don't think I did I don't think you did
because there's a bigger bike culture in
London I'm talking about app accessed
scooters I mean we are in the peak I
believe scooters scootering around
American cities and there's quite a
competition going right now I mean in
one in a couple of the cities we saw
late four or five different companies
you got lime you got bird you got lift
getting into it you got goober getting
into it and there was like two other
ones I can't remember the names like
jump flip skip stop something like that
roller buddies roller but who doesn't
fit on a scooter two wheels one cup I
think was one of them I think it's two
wheels one foot that's it
that was it that's ours two wheels no
helmet that's what they call me
because incidentally that's another
thing anytime you know firstly you got
to download the apps for each one of
these services and then like the first
time you download the app you sign you
agree to return to a lot of things and
one of the terms is course you will wear
a helmet but literally no one on any
scooter at any time that we saw had a
helmet on well I mean so the when we
were in st. Louis I mean we we we went
to a barbecue place and then we went to
the the Gateway Arch which I believe is
six hundred and thirty feet tall well I
looked that up and then I don't remember
numbers so I'm probably wrong but I
think I'm right
it feels really it up very reason well
we were going to go up there but we
didn't have time to to book a tour you
can take a friggin sideways or arch past
elevator to the top of this thing but we
couldn't do that so we just walked
around the bottom of it and we're
walking around down there and it's you
got all these pavers and it's like
undulating terrain just little Hills but
there are some steps and there are some
steps that then become undulating
terrain and ramps and as we're walking
it was me
Rhett and Britain and I see these two
girls are probably like 15 and they were
careening in front of us on two of these
scooters and the girl in front zip spy
us and then she turns around and she
yells don't go on the stairs and that
drew my eye to her so I didn't actually
see what happened but you did well the
way that the train was set up there was
a blind spot essentially so just from
from your perspective it just like you
were gonna continue on straight ground
but really there was like a three
maybe two or three step drop she in of
concrete yeah and the steps were such
that the further left you were the more
steps there were to go down and she just
happened to choose a a line that was
like two or three steps like two or
three feet to the left and it would've
been five or six steps like it was
anyway did she take flight well like you
said her friend said at the last minute
don't go off there or whatever and that
was exactly the wrong thing to say
because she basically dismounted in the
air and the scooter landed really really
hard
she actually landed on her feet it's
been really really ugly and she landed
on her feet and was like immediately
like plop plop-plop-plop-plop like
running in a very awkward fashion but
she I mean she could have she could've
hit her head on that on the concrete and
died man we could have witnessed the
death well I could have witnessed her
friend witnessing the death because I
was looking at the wrong girl well and
that's the main thing that you're that
I'm thinking the whole time I'm on there
they go like 20 miles per hour and eat
faster than that if you're going
downhill and the wheels are relatively
small you know there's not necessarily
Mirai in bike lanes
it went possible but most American
cities are not very Bart bike friendly
so right there's very few bike lanes a
lot of people don't know where to go
they go on the sidewalks they when
they're in the street there might be
potholes people don't have good balance
people aren't wearing helmets and so
there's this crazy thing that's
happening where all these companies are
competing against each other to try to
win this market yeah but at the same
time people are getting hurt well when
we were in Austin there was this makeup
woman and we happen to start talking to
her about the scooters because we saw
him around Austin and she said yeah my
husband was on one and he went off a
curb and fell over and hurt his leg and
really badly like he was he was in a lot
of pain and the paramedics show up and
after a while they're like you're okay
just go home and he went home that night
and he woke up in excruciating pain and
she said that he like was in so much
pain that he started to go into shock
and so she took him to the emergency
room and he had broken his femur on a
freaking scooter guys yeah and the
helmet doesn't protect the femur last
time I checked well if you get a femur
helmet that's what we need so so two
wheels one foot is gonna we're gonna
figure out a way to like attach the
helmet to the scooter and also have like
femur pads right I mean you can really
get hurt because you think you can ride
a scooter but you don't realize how fast
these things can go and also you're
tempted to just steer like left right
left right inky inky inky but you're you
you really should steer by leaning to be
using your body way you got to be using
your body weight but it that's not
immediately intuitive and it's I mean if
you start doing that then you're doing
and the shaky shaky shaky thing and then
you're like you're careening out of
control
people are locals hate these things I
mean so when we have to when we were in
Nashville that by that point
Britain's friends had showed up Jenna
was with us at a time so it was like
there was like six of us a little pod
going down the street basically the main
drag in Nashville and as it as we
continued going down we started
realizing like this has almost become a
highway like people are like turning off
of this to get on the interstate there's
only a few stoplights there's no bike
lane and we're right up against what
we're going across a bridge and like the
six of us in a line are kind of taking
up the lane and people are just laying
on their horns the locals hate us and
they should and but we were doing the
right thing because you're not supposed
to be on the sidewalk you're supposed to
be like a bike but they were just laying
on the horn I guess it was because some
of us were like waggling it goes beyond
that though because I think what they're
trying to do is they're trying to say
don't be here like go on a less busy
street where a freaking helmet you know
and we we were talking to go back to
whatever town you're from talking to
Britain's friends and apparently in
Raleigh North Carolina they were they've
gotten rid of all of them oh really
babies
gotten rid of all the scooters is what
we were told I haven't been there to
confirm this because they couldn't
figure out how to regulate them and then
the companies were like well screw it
we're not gonna be a part of this I just
don't know where this is gonna land
because people are gonna are are getting
hurt and they're gonna continue her I
personally but when when I love it when
we run absolutely love it yeah so when
we were in Columbus I mean I looked out
my hotel window and I saw a couple of
people like we were downtown by like by
the river and like this is like nice
river walks on either side of it and I
saw some people with scooters I was like
bingo we're gonna do it because we
didn't do it in st. Louis I just saw the
girls almost a girl almost eat it and
then the next morning Here I am still
thinking it's a great idea and you know
what it was oh it was fun I mean when
you're when you're not just going on the
surface streets like in a downtown area
with a lot of traffic but you're on like
a dedicated path and a relatively fresh
one that doesn't have like a bunch of
treachery to it that was fun man the
weather was great it was yeah it was
beautiful it was a highlight of the trip
was but scooting around man
[Applause]
being off of the road I would say that
being on a not busy road or being on
like a park path park path is that is
Peak scooter terrain but you know what I
think I'm gonna start traveling with a
helmet okay get a little helmet man you
laugh you laugh now but you're not gonna
laugh when you when you don't remember
how to laugh cuz you hit your head
there's something about being on a
scooter though that makes me feel
because I my feet are so close to the
ground already I feel like I can just
like jump out of any tear any situation
any danger you can just immediately jump
and be standing up whereas like a
motorcycle you're going a lot faster
yeah you know your feet are really close
to the ground on a motorcycle too but
you can't just walk off of a motorcycle
if you ride sidesaddle you can't yeah I
don't run my motorcycle so I said like
I'm or you ride you how do you ride your
horse sidesaddle backwards you don't
want anybody sneaking up on me I ride my
horses backwards so I don't know I don't
know what the future of scootering is
gonna be but I they can't tether the
helmets to the thing because then that's
a that's a hazard you gotta lice Oh lice
- yeah it's a lice hazard oh she is that
what you mean but no I mean like if
there's a string a tether so that people
won't walk away with the helmets I think
you need a helmet sharing app same
company different company different
company we should do the helmet sharing
so you're gonna have to like walk to the
helmet and then what then the problem
with people be scootering to the helm
you got a yes no you got a sign in no no
you know it's got to be the same company
and you can't it's like one of those
things after you get a few duis you
can't start a car without breathing into
it this is like you have to like step on
you have to like hit you gotta kind of
bother hit ahead but the scooter with
the helmet so you got to be to going or
just be willing to headbutt the scooter
really hard without a helmet to make it
seem like I think if they had a helmet
that was like a zip tie kind of not zip
tied but like a zip line like it comes
out from the the handlebars and then
you're kind of like
loosely tethered to the thing it's kind
of like sounds like it might be more
dangerous kind of like it's got a like I
got a narrow roof on it it's like have
you ever seen those bikes that would
have like a shell on them yeah like an
aerodynamic shell like have one of those
come off the handlebars OOP goes over
your whole head then it's just like a
little car that's not fun you don't feel
the breeze anymore I want to feel the
breeze that's half of it okay anyway
y'all gotta figure that out and I don't
know who's gonna win this but yeah I
don't know if I would invest in my gut
is that this is this is not sustainable
but if it ends up being sustainable I
think it I think it is my gut says that
now that lift and apparently uber is in
this game I feel like they're gonna win
because I already got that app yeah
because that the main barriers like I
got a download something man I don't
have good servers here
well yeah take pictures of my license I
don't travel with my life I've never
been so willing to download an app as
when I was about to get on a scooter I
will say that like when I'm about to get
on a scooter I'll download any app I
mean it could be like a credit card
number sharing app like hack me.com app
I would download that just that's how
excited I wasn't dead set on getting on
that scooter interesting yeah I would I
would agree to anything I mean I
basically signed my life away yeah I'm
wearing a helmet I'm hard-headed and
then people are taking them home and
charging them up and making a little
extra scratch you know yeah it's good
for everybody and they're not
gas-powered technically it's good for
the maybe it's not too late maybe the
environment we can get in on this
mythical scooters you know what we make
ours three-wheeled safer safer
sure like shaped like a pyramid it's
double wheeled in the back now two
wheels in the front like it when a kids
learn how to ride a scooter yeah like a
spider yeah and we marketed to children
that's what we do we're gonna do that
but first we're just gonna promote what
we got which is this hat it's a GMM hat
he's got some camouflage to it it's got
some orange to it it's got accoutrements
we also got mugs the ear biscuits mug
it's beige it's so good to drink out of
its hefty once you once you get this
thing you'll be like man this is a high
quality mug
oh if Elmen wants me to say that it's
cream I go with beige
I think beige is one of the most
pleasing colors of nature it is the
color of most things you know when the
world ends when the universe finally
just dissipates into nothingness it will
be dissipating into beige beige is the
entropy of color beige is before all
things and after all things beige but I
would venture to guess before and after
all the things would be just blackness
no it's beige miss that that's that's a
common misconception I'm glad you said
it straight because you had that
knowledge beige miss in the beginning
you know where the gun was baseness
mythical dot store reputable is drink
drink from the cup of biscuit okay so a
couple of interesting things about this
tour now as we have as we've stated
repeatedly but it cannot be overstated
apparently because even some of the VIPs
who showed up to meet and greet us after
a few of the shows multiple people would
say something along these lines man I I
didn't know you guys played music I mean
like I thought this was gonna be like
two hours of will at burrito somebody
said that specifically yeah anything
like that would be a big burrito now I
do under we could do it and we would do
it and we might do it yeah that's a
great idea but that's we didn't just do
it not this year I think that it's a
little we have a little bit of a
branding problem right because the thing
that we're known for the most is good
mythical
morning and let's be honest if you were
to watch just like a little highlight
reel of what we do on the show you might
not come to the conclusion that these
two idiots had any other talents other
than we also got being able to eat
things yeah I think someone said I
didn't know you guys were talented how
we got and these are like these are like
fans paying to meet us I mean these are
like true mythical beasts I didn't know
you know but things come out sideways
when you're meeting somebody that you've
watched a lot on the internet so I just
find humor in it but I know they didn't
mean anything by it well I'm like and on
top of that another thing I'll say is
that let's say that you're a fan of GMM
and you've been watching that and then
the and then what you have seen of our
other work is say our really popular rap
battles or other music videos that we
made on YouTube again anybody can make a
music video anybody can sing along with
the track anybody can have their voice
auto-tuned so I think a lot of people
are just like oh well of course yeah you
got music videos but to sit down and for
almost two hours for us to do live
instrument based music is something that
a lot of people just aren't expecting
but again as we explain it every show
one of the things that's really cool
about it is that it's sort of a
returning to the roots of what we we did
before this whole before YouTube started
we were prior comedy was primarily just
funny songs that we performed live for
people and then we turned some of those
in the music videos and that was sort of
the beginning of our comedy career so
this is kind of going back to what
started at all and anyway it's really
fun to do I'm I'm very glad that this is
what we decided to do when we now tour
and by the way we are continuing to tour
so if you want to come see us rhett and
Link live.com can I plug the dates I
should place them look at Las Vegas on
June 21st Salt Lake City 22nd Denver to
the 23rd Milwaukee the 25th Indianapolis
26 Detroit the 27th Omaha the 29th
Minneapolis the 30th rhett and Link
come get your tickets I'm I just had
such a good time because you know I
really enjoy singing the songs that
we've written over the years and but it
also does capture a lot and I think of
what people like about good mythical
morning and that's the fact that we can
kind of you know it's not scripted we're
just kind of in between songs were just
kind of cutting up and seeing what
happens and on any given night you never
know what's gonna happen I mean at the
beginning the songs were we were a
little more rusty than by the time we
got to Nashville we kind of had the
songs down and we weren't gonna forget
lyrics or stuff like that but like on
the first night one of the new songs
when you moved over to the piano like
you started playing it then you never
started singing and I'm like he doesn't
remember the lyrics and all of a sudden
you're like I can't remember the words
and that was the most fun part of the
night because are you it was real fun
for you when something goes wrong it's
like okay everybody in the whole place
knows this was not planned so now what
are we gonna do and so that's what's fun
is that when you you don't have to wig
out you're gonna say you can just have
fun with it
and that was fun I had fun messing with
you and not I knew the lyrics so I I
didn't want a chose not to tell you and
kind of make you squirm but I said there
and played the piano for what felt like
five minutes play the intro people loved
it oh I know people loved it I'm just
saying this is honest I was like I
really don't know how to access what the
first the first words of this song are
but like you said by the time we got to
Nashville this week we had the songs for
Utah I think the thing is is that I
don't mind and actually I look forward
to you know what's gonna happen in
between the songs and what stories are
we gonna tell and it's very it's very
loose and where they're gonna go or what
what kind of bit are we gonna just come
up with in the moment but I don't I
don't want all the bits to come from
fail screwing the songs up what they
didn't and they didn't they didn't in
because I again I I also I have a lot
more fun the more I know the song it
frees you up to them and then I can
actually have good to have fun in the in
the midst of it because you know it's
like it's it's just one of those it's
it's it's a it's a little bit of a
blessing and a curse that we get to do
so many things but because we do so many
things it isn't like we sit around and
like rehearse write our musical exam we
don't rehearse enough we've been we turn
again we turn the mess ups into okay we
can we can make fun of that happening
and we can we can kind of milk it for
comedy but and maybe well it's also a
very safe maybe will happen I mean my
goal is for us to have at least another
new song that no one has heard at all by
the time we yeah enjoy out on the summer
tour but it's also great I'm very
grateful that it's such a safe space for
us or to perform because everybody is
even if they didn't know what to expect
they're a dedicated mythical beast and
there's or they're there they're there
with someone who's already oriented to
what's going on so it's not like we have
to win the crowd over we just have to
give them we just have to have fun and I
think it was a lot of fun and I imagine
how if you're if touring is your first
thing and you're trying to win over a
crowd and trying to build an audience
that way it's like that would be
difficult so it's nice that we don't
yeah we don't have to do that well but
you know speaking of winning over a
crowd who's not familiar with you I mean
one of the things that made this tour
unique was Britain opening up for us
yeah and of course you know we talked
about Britain a lot Britain Buchanan
links cousin who was on the voice and
his living with Lincoln Christie now and
we did we honestly didn't know how that
was going to go because his songs are
not it's not comedy right he's just like
a legitimately great songwriter and
musician and singer and so we were like
well we enjoy this we think you'll enjoy
it too and you know that there's the
family connection but we would we would
kind of go out and watch not go out into
the crowd but kind of go side stage and
watch Britain perform and it's like
saying
you to all the mythical beasts who
received him so warmly but I'll say that
you weren't doing it out of any sort of
obligation or pity I think everyone was
legit before everything that I've seen
on the internet everybody was
legitimately impressed because he's good
yeah
and he did a good job when it winning
people over with like this stuff that he
would say in between songs too so yeah
we want Savoy we won't spoil any
surprises I think I think we're gonna
talk a little bit more a little bit more
about what Britain does on tour on LTAC
but we won't get into that too much here
but that we also traveled with him yeah
he was he was with us the entire time
speaking of travelling so we were I mean
we have like the tour bus situation and
then on the tour bus you got the front
part and then you go back to the middle
part and there's these like I call them
coffins you sleep in a coffin
they're like too high on some buses
they're three high well these were these
were snowing I mean you can imagine the
first time we did this it was there were
three high so you can't sit up and and I
I can't even LA can't lay all the way
down it's it's the they don't make them
six-foot-seven these things are probably
six two six three ah I could stretch I
could stretch out I think they might not
stick I think they might be just below
my height I think it may be like six and
a half feet plus the siding or whatever
is there like six five so how do you
sleep in there well not well because you
can't in to begin with I'll say for a
couple of reasons I mean not being able
to stretch out I sleep on my side so I'm
not at full height you know I sleep like
a baby in the womb and like with your
knees under your chin I mean if I can
get him there yeah completely balled up
ready to for tornadoes and like in a
tuck position no I sleep on my side so
I'm a little bit curled up but even like
in my bed if I'm sleeping on my side
there's moments during the night we're
all kind of wake up and I'll just like
for a moment just sort of stretch out
completely because unfurl the flag just
to like remember my point you know and
and then turn to the other side so you
can't do that
and also I'm such a light sleeper that
PAHO I wake up fast turn I wake up oh
yeah that's not fun
but I did get better I did get better
all that on the second night I like
sleeping in a confined space I mean I
don't know something about it I just
felt like I felt like a cozy little
child if it was a little bit longer and
we weren't gone it would be great once
we arrived but thought once we arrived
to the to the destination and then they
kind of let you wake up on your own
whenever you happen to wake up and the
bus I'll sleep indefinitely in that
scenario well but you didn't could well
I I mean that first morning there I woke
up and I realized I was started what you
don't realize what I'm moving and you're
like your your coffin has a curtain so
it's like it's pretty dark in there even
if it's bright outside which it turns
out it was because I looked out my
curtain and then I got a text from Jenna
she was like instructions are on the
counter when you want to come into the
hotel
wherever and I assumed where everybody
else already was because I didn't hear
anything
and then so I got out no one was on the
bus and then I look in Britain's
curtains closed and I'm like I didn't
open the curtain because I didn't know
what position or state he might be in
and - in terms of clothing so I just
poked the curtain and I did hit
something so I'm like oh he is in there
and I was like time to get up it was
11:30 we were Britt and I were the only
two people on the bus and then we like
we oriented ourselves and we go to eggs
at the bus and Britain like goes down
the steps and he's like turns the
doorknob it doesn't doesn't respond and
then he's like shaking on the I was like
really pulling on the lever and I'm like
well hold on I'll break the door we're
and he's like we're locked in man I'm
like what no we're not just you know and
we start and you look at the front of
this bus which we don't know anything
about there's buttons there it's like
the cockpit of a airplane there's
buttons everywhere
so we start pushing all of them
and we push the ones that look like they
have something to do with a door right
and I heard something click around the
door but then it still went open like
here and then I'm over there like
putting all my weight onto it we get
we're locked on the bus for for a day
the whole day no we eventually got off
but that was our first bus experience I
like sleeping on the bus but I don't
like I don't like being confined and not
being able to exit the bus that's a
little disconcerting well that raises an
interesting question
are there other exits is there an exit
in the back because there [ __ ]
there should be exits because what do
you think about this now or there's a
fire on the bus there should be multiple
exits I guess we need an orientation
isn't there like oh there's I mean
there's a obviously there's like a exit
in the back of a school bus there but
it's a room in the back of this thing
there's exits on the roof of a school
bus and every a window is an exit like
if the school bus like lays on his side
or something you can go out the top of a
school bus right yeah yeah a window you
can get out of a school bus to lots of
different ways every which way and you
don't need a button need no button maybe
we should be traveling in a school bus
I'm just saying I well you do have me
thinking that now I need started
checking for exits a little worried
that's why Christie should have come
with me I know that's the first thing
she looks for it's the exit not
everything I mean not our relationship
we're doing great
mm-hmm interesting we played at Columbus
that night once I got out of the bus and
got off the scooter that was fun that
was a great show I mean III in general
I'll just shout out thanks to all the
crowds everywhere super supportive and
then when we do the meet-and-greet
afterward it's it's always special
because you kind of get to hear just a
little bit from fans in terms of how
they watch the show what what watching
us means to them and it always blows me
away how
the nature of our show being daily and I
guess the our friendship and I mean
there's a lot of intangibles that like
being on the inside you it's it's just
hard to get perspective on how people
enjoy the show or what it what it means
to them and helps them get through hard
times and they can count on it and stuff
like that so it's it's really helpful to
to get out there and meet the people you
know to press the flesh it really puts
things in perspective but you I mean
everything is said that last part I
understand I mean yeah yes
I don't i press the flesh is not the
right word you can't that's that was a
political term I can't use it was that
well that was first handshakes and we
don't we we don't if you want a hug we
hug whatever we let you initiate
whatever you want to do but yeah I mean
I think that so flesh is pressed but I
mean it's upon an itchy they're in it
yeah I just don't like to use flesh and
pressed in the context of the meet and
greet I just that's it's kind of I would
like to abandon that terminal yeah let's
abandon it let's lock it in the bus but
I you know I did see some people on
Twitter talking before this this run and
they were saying you know I just I don't
know I don't know I'm nervous I don't
know what to say and and I think people
will have a tendency to feel like they
have to have some sort of
something-something prepared or as if
they're like auditioning to be the
perfect mythical beast in that moment
and that's not what it's about at all I
mean you know what you whatever you want
to do I mean we have one girl who sang
for us got another guy who performed a
rap in violence you know and those are
awesome is hilarious if you want to do
that do that mean it was supposed to be
funny and we don't we don't encourage
everyone to do to do that because I mean
we'd be there for 7 hours of everyone
had a performance we'd like for you to
perform of some sort of bring your
talent but ultimately what I'm saying
some people are like you know what I
just I'm gonna hand you this note
because this is everything that I want
to say and I don't you know it I some
it's more than I have time to say in
this time and there some people are just
like hey I just want a picture whatever
you want it to be just know that like
we're not
like the way that we approach this is we
are 100% grateful like it's just
we are in a attitude of gratitude a
stance of mmm France something that
rhymes with Stan like we're basically
just humbled that you guys come to the
show that some of you want to spend a
little time with us and get a picture
and we're just happy that you're there
you don't have to say or do anything
you're not fitting any particular
expectation so if that makes you feel
less nervous about it then go with that
because we're not we're not thinking
about it in that way in fact you know
III I heard there was one girl and one
of the shows who actually backed out of
the line now before she got to the end
and I think we were gonna end up sending
her something it's in her all the stuff
that she would have gotten in the in the
meet and greet line but it's kind of
nervous some people deal with anxiety it
is whatever I get it it's never I can
just stand in a line to meet somebody
oh I totally get that because it's I
mean you can see it the line just kind
of move along and then all of a sudden
you're like the next person I remember a
few years back when dantdm came to Long
Beach and like Lincoln was a fan of his
and I was like I can get you I can get
you in to see him and I got connections
and um so we went in a meet and greet
line and we're in the line and I
realized that I was nervous I was like
why am i nervous just just by virtue of
a being in a line with a bunch of people
who are like also nervous it's like
contagious yeah and it doesn't you build
this expectation it's like there is this
moment of okay we're gonna shake hands
and I'm supposed to say something I have
to say something if I don't say anything
that's that could be weird you know yeah
but even the people who don't say
anything yes it's not weird
everything like that does mean lashes
what so I mean yeah I'm not and I'm not
saying at all don't be
be nervous I'm just saying just be
yourself if yourself is nervous then be
nervous if yourself is excited then just
be excited and there's no there's no
judgement at all from us and I know
listen we're bigger than you three lies
physically I am I know that i am in
intimidating physically people are
sometimes afraid to look at me because I
think I'm just like I look like God I
look like
Detlef Schrempf or whatever that mp8
basketball player was you know I'm a
huge person I have a lot of hair on my
face you know I look like a hawk we I
think I've been called a falcon by a
drunk man in a van one time you do it
like a foul man
I like a tall Detlef Schrempf looking
falcon but i'm very soft and inviting
you know I have sweaty hands you can
shake them if you want we should talk
about hot chicken so we get to Nashville
and we had a little more time in
Nashville because we had like a one-day
break and mayhem by the time I got in
line it we decided to go to Hattie B's
even though mythical chef Josh told us
to get hot chicken from Bolton's spicy
chicken and fish and even though
wikipedia says that princes is the
originator of hot chicken and we didn't
go there
we we were kind of starving delirious
and closest to Hattie B's and also we
tend to be very dependent upon Yelp and
there's a lot of mini Yelp reviews a lot
of people love don't like that don't I
mean don't like when you're that
dependent on you up but like I just you
know like 4000 reviews four and a half
stars like you know it's gonna be good
and we get there we scooter there of
course we did and then nearly died we're
there for a couple of minutes and then
we hear
well it's 45 minutes from where you are
in line yeah cuz I being its own Space
Mountain show
starving I was like I don't I don't wait
this long for I just don't it doesn't
add up I started looking for Bolton's
me like we can travel to Bolton this via
scooter eat and be done and still come
back and not have gone through this line
probably right but that to me that's all
part of the experience of going to a
place like that and I will say I do
think it's worth noting that you know
hot chicken has been exported from
Nashville and of course it's in LA and
there's a number of places that serve it
Hal and Ray's probably being the most
popular and I have seen the Holland
Ray's line before but neither of us and
I don't know if we were just holding out
for Nashville or just happened
circumstantially and never been there we
had never had hot chicken well you know
we did our Instagram stories from the
line and then we finally get up there
and we order and it's I you know what
I'll agree with you I actually ended up
saying I'll say it again I'm glad that I
waited 45 minutes and I kind of learned
my lesson it really but I mean you talk
about getting nervous in a line I mean I
in this type of line when the only thing
you got to do is pay and eat food boy
that's a great scenario
I mean you that's a great payoff and it
and you're talking like Magic Mountain
or spacing out we should serve hot
chicken in the meet-and-greet I'm saying
contrast to that you you don't have to
say anything besides the order what you
want at the end and then you really got
to pick your spice but my point is the
lot the weight made it taste that much
better
oh yeah and we bow to late gratification
man it's the spice of life it's the hot
chicken of life and so I you know I
don't like spicy foods I've been burned
pun intended from the show so now
anything that's spicy to me is like it's
triggering physically so I start to feel
a little nauseous but I I didn't want to
just try mild or medium I'm like if it's
called hot chicken I should order a hot
and for those of you who aren't familiar
with it because I had an idea of what I
thought the hot chicken was fried
chicken with hot sauce on it like based
it on it
not wing but it is not that it is
chicken that has spice actually in the
the breading first of all so that's the
first thing that happens it's so if you
were to like peel back the skin you
would see like a little red layer of
spice that has is part of the so it gets
all the way onto the chicken and then on
top of that depending on what spice
level you get they add a dry rub and I'm
sure there's some places that do a sauce
but these places do a dry rub on top of
so it's basically like a powdery thing
it's not I think there might be some
sauce as well on Hattie B's I couldn't
really know there's a dryness and a
wetness to it but there's definitely a
redness to it that makes it a bit
intimidating and I was so hungry but the
levels were southern which means no
spice and yes someone in our group who
will remain nameless but he's one of
Britain's friends that's what he got no
one who worked for us he's also a
Carolina fan so it all adds up the next
the next level is mild and then medium
and then hot and then damn hot and then
shut the cluck up those are the levels
and we all went with hot so Jenna got
hot we got hot Britton got hot and let
me tell you it was hot but let me tell
you something else it tasted great like
my hotness tasted great much flavor and
it was it was big and juicy oh it was so
good I mean it was and you you got the
dark I love a good I got love a good
food experience man you know and it I
think it's turned me back on the hotness
when I'm when I'm riding back home
coming back we landed in LA it's an hour
drive to get back to the studio to get
in our cars I found myself on Yelp
looking for the hot chicken places
around here and there's quite a man I'm
I'm back on the spicy train we might
have to have a hot chicken taste test
the instagrams troilite when we went
around and tried to find the best taco
to do that with hot chicken but I did
not order like the upper echelon of Hot
Wheels so how you did so you can get a
tender or a wing by itself for two
dollars extra and add that to your order
so a lot of people do this just as a
novelty kind of thing so I had a show
you know uh uh you know also I feel like
I've eaten the world's hottest pepper
twice so I was like you know what I'm
just gonna do a damn hot tender and then
Britain
you know he's 19 his body can take
anything at this point
he got a shut the cluck up wing no a
tender he got a shut the cluck up tender
and if you if you were following along
on our Instagram stories read em see in
link lamont you would have kissed you
would have seen all this happen and
Britain's I guess he Britain Buchan and
follow him on Instagram too because the
actions happening over there when we're
traveling it was funny cuz he thought he
was gonna be alright and then is his
face just started crying his eyeballs
just sweated right he cried quite a bit
yeah yeah the damn hot
tinder was damn hot but it was like as I
was eating it I was like I could have
gotten the sandwich this way well he and
I would have been okay he texted at us
and said that his dad looked into it cuz
he tried to talk to dad and even when he
said that it had the top at the top
showed the clock up yeah it had scorpion
pepper and ghost pepper in the oven or
equal parts of all Furnish and it's like
a powder which is incidentally it's like
the heat is super intense but it
dissipates more quickly because it
doesn't have an oil base to it the way
that it doesn't have an oil carrier the
way that sauce does cuz sauce will get
into your skin because literally like
you know like when you you get like
essential oils and you put them into
like a olive oil carrier so they'll like
yeah carried further and then go into
your skin
that's why eating the pepper straight
because you've got that oil and then
even worse when you need a sauce it
sticks with you you feel it later you
feel it in your stomach you feel it on
the way out and it's still
incredibly hot in each stage something
about the dry rub makes this looks like
a flash bang of hotness but for me an
hour later I forgotten that I ate
something so even when you're eating it
I highly recommend eating it with the
slaw which was great yes they call me
the pickle and the like the bread that
comes you got every creamy side oh you
got the mac and cheese potato salad and
this law I did and I ended up getting
collard greens and beans of course the
beans are good that doesn't help but
they but they actually the collard
greens that had this like enhancing
effect because of the vinegar like it
that's tough
so anyway Hattie B's was excellent but
of course because we didn't want to come
back and face Josh and also Josh made an
incredible dinner reservation too for a
place called husk that we went that was
that was amazing one of the best meals
shout out to shout out to all you people
working at husk the people in the
kitchen knew who we were and started
sending out stuff that we didn't order
and they stuffed us like pigs they
stuffed us with pigs yeah crazy and
every it was amazing first of all the
waitress described the items and I feel
like she spoke for like 12 minutes
unbroken describing two different items
and she would say things like well first
we take this and we put it in under
ashes for 12 hours and then we take it
and we rub it across a pig's back until
it squeals and then we capture the
squeal and we put it in a bottle and we
sprinkle it on top of the collards and
then we take the college and we run them
into the past and then we bring them out
of the past once they have the essence
of the old days and then we bring them
to the table and then we grind them up
and sprinkle them on the other foods
that they will be enjoying I mean I had
a freaking whiskey with ham in it yeah
that was crazy man it was so good what a
night and it was it's in an old house
it's in an old house that parently is
haunted so
husk we can go to husk it was a surgeon
from like the Civil War yeah but so Josh
told us to go to there so we felt like
we had to follow his recommendation but
we also felt like we couldn't come back
until we went to Bolton's hot chicken
and fish
yeah spicy chicken and fish that's what
it's called
I got a cockatrice breathing fine well
they got a chicken breathing fire out
front again
Instagram yeah we showed you this
they've got a sign when you order there
and it says basically proceed at your
own risk
do not touch your eyes or babies when
eating our hot chicken and fish and do
not touch babies and someone had said
think about that how bad would you feel
if like you get you get you salsa baby
oh man I'm sorry I just sauce your baby
well it's really dry rubbing a baby I'm
so sorry I didn't mean to dry rub your
baby yeah I mean if you if you've got a
nasty habit of dry rub and a baby in the
eyes do not go to Nashville
Yeah right yeah you're not even invited
mm-hmm like you cannot first of all
that's a habit you need to break what
are you doing touch of baby's eyes yeah
like if a baby's got an eye booger who
cares just let them have it it's
actually probably a good thing it's like
a protective layer at the corner of the
eyes yeah you don't need to I think in
general you shouldn't touch the face of
a baby
don't touch baby's faces yeah eyes like
oh look at that baby's so cute can I rub
its eyes what mm-hmm and you have to put
up a sign I mean what does that say
about the people in Nashville it means a
lot of baby a dry rub in baby's eye
touches they dry rub and baby's left and
right before they put that sign up there
for the baby the spice levels at Bolton
are it's a different scale we were told
this there's no spice and then there's
light or something like that then
there's mild then there's medium then
there's hot but they said whatever you
got it Hattie B's is what we were told
by two different people go one level
lower I'm grateful that we did so we got
so yeah and they were right so the
difference is hotter an experience hot
there was
medium at Bolton's and they don't have a
sandwich there it's just the fried
chicken
similar sides I tried the beans actually
well I'll just go ahead and say that not
just Josh but most Nashvillians
that we ran into and said we had been to
Hattie B's they had this disappointed
look on their face they were like of
course you guys did the touristy thing
you should really go to Bolton so she go
to Princess mm-hmm guys and we did well
we went to one and it's not the business
was really really good really good and
the atmosphere was like so authentic
it's like cinderblock buildings that
look like um look like bunkers almost
look like I was eating at a barbecue
bunker right really it's really rustic
but we got to say we both enjoyed Hattie
B's more I mean it was just it was more
of a distinct thing now they do have
they do have hot fish you can get all
the same spices on the fish at Bolton's
and so we got a hot fish so we went all
the way too hot and then they got
whitefish
they got catfish they got group where we
got the white fish because it was at the
top of the menu we figured that was the
one that was suggested I would recommend
doing both though yeah you should try
that I didn't cuz I've never had a spicy
fish like that but was very good we
should skip to the Ryman because because
we're at this point not conversation we
haven't gotten to it but yeah being a
fan of old country music and you know we
went through the Country Music Hall of
Fame and took our time had a great time
they had an outlaws exhibit which was
amazing but in a lot of the pictures
that you'll see throughout the Country
Music Hall of Fame
you see people performing at the Ryman
Auditorium because it was the home of
the Grand Ole Opry for 30 years
it was the distinct m'as the place where
country country music legends were were
made and certified yeah so basically how
can anybody who's anybody
in country music like old country yeah
has played and then of course Hank will
you know the new axe had played there as
well the Grassley got playing there
incredible history and but but the the
Ryman Auditorium was originally built as
a as an actual church like a revival
venue and the you can totally tell but
when you go in there because it's all
pews it's all a big circle it's a huge
balcony that it follows the same
semicircular pattern and then you've got
the stained glass windows I mean super
famous it's super famous for the history
but it's also super famous for the
acoustics because it's all wood yeah and
it's in the circular thing it's just
like it's one of the best sounding
places and I'm joining play music I'm
doing some research when we're in DC I'm
I want to I want to see Merle playing
here and I mean he first played there
and as you started his career in 1967
but then Johnny Cash who was a member of
the Grand Ole Opry and was then kicked
out and you can see that in the movie
walk the line he was he was a let go but
then he came back when he had his own
television show the Johnny Cash show he
insisted that it be filmed at the Ryman
Auditorium at the same at the home of
the Grand Ole Opry so they would film
his show there and I mean Johnny Cash is
bringing Bob Dylan on his show I mean
this is this is an amazing institution
within an institution just his show and
he had as Merle was gaining popularity
he comes on the show and the scene the
two of them interact is like it just
gives me goosebumps thinking about that
footage but one story in particular is
amazing that of course Merle was Merle
was in prison and just like the lyric
and mama tried he did turn 21 in prison
he wasn't serving life without parole
but 15 years um and Johnny Cash knew
this but he encouraged
Murrell to talk about it openly his time
in prison which he hadn't done now some
people knew that he had been in prison
but it was on the Johnny Cash show on
the stage that we performed on that
Merle in a conversation with Johnny Cash
told the world for the first time that
he was he was a prisoner he wasn't he
was an ex-con and not only that he told
it in the context of the story of when
Johnny Cash on many occasions would go
and perform concerts at prisons Folsom
Prison concert his famous album but so
is his San Quentin performance but he
performed at San Quentin a number of
times and one of those times Merle
Haggard was in the audience as a frickin
inmate and he's like telling that story
so it's basically his coming out that
hey I was an ex-con and blowing people's
minds that Johnny I was at your concert
as an inmate and so and to know that
happened on that stage just kind of blew
my mind and then I realized I'm getting
nervous
well I I was I was already nervous
before we went to the Hall of Fame you
know because first of all everyone who
we talked to if we say we're playing The
Rime light will your plane over I'm
really like yeah you're going to this
sacred place and I'm also thinking about
the thing that it is that we do which is
we're not we're not country musicians I
mean we're gonna being we're gonna be
adding like fools up in his place yeah
you know I mean we're playing music but
it's stupid in a lot of ways we got a
lot of testicle jokes yeah
and so and we've got a whole rap set
which feels weird feels a little out of
place in Ryman but so in seeing all that
footage you know people who made their
debut there in the in because one of the
cool things about the Country Music Hall
of Fame in addition to like the
memorabilia the archival sort of stuff
are the artifacts is all the video that
they have in there right they've got so
in all these
like you said the footage of the
conversation on the Johnny Cash show
with Merle but so much of that in so
many pictures on it that's the Ryman
that's the Ryman to ask the Ryman and
then I kept saying like we're playing
there tonight and I started thinking a
couple things like eh I'm Way more
nervous than I usually am before a show
and - we had decided to play - Merle
songs - her favorite Merle song which is
not that we never done we don't cover
anybody's songs and we've we've never
performed Merle songs publicly and I can
remember right and so you know we did we
did one that is a really popular
old-school Merle song and then one
that's a little bit of a deeper cut and
I was thinking I might cry Oh
I was like I don't want I you know I
don't want to cry during this thing
because I can't cry and still continue
to sing I'm not one of those people who
can like you know crisis pricing some
people can kind of like Vince Gill I
seems like he's always crying I hate my
voice would break and so I was like I
don't want that to happen so you know I
don't know how I'm gonna take my mind
off that but a few things about the show
I mean first of all thankfully we did
have everything down from a musical
standpoint but right we got there it did
sound like we could hear ourselves
really well and you can't you sort of
feel the power of the of the music kind
of going out and coming around that
circle and coming back to you and also
you can hear every single thing that is
being the crowd reaction is so immediate
because they're right there on you and
it's it's 2,200 people it's a small
small venue and they're kind of on top
of you and a lot of ways because you've
got that huge balcony ya know the
furthest person from you is still
relatively close and it makes such a big
difference I mean in a little bit of
touring that we've done it's like every
venue is different in it and you never
know exactly what you're gonna get and
what crowd is going to show up but
everything lined up I mean the crowd was
so boisterous and responsive you know I
had somebody I don't know how we got to
this like me asking for antibacterial
soap and then somebody's like throwing
hands in it up hand sanitizer up at me
and like empty the entire bottle that
she threw to me into my hand and then I
didn't know what to do with it and like
we came up with something it was a lot
of fun man everybody was just loved
everybody was having a good time so by
the time in the middle of the set when
we we we performed silver wings you felt
like you weren't gonna cry because
people like it was people said that they
cried it was and I was like yes it was
very very emotional for me like playing
but right and then driftwood and played
we played driftwood with Britain he got
out there and killed the solo the guitar
solo and it was emotional for sure but I
didn't think that I was gonna like break
down at that moment so the show just
went on it was great and we got to that
last song that we sing which is a little
bit of an emotional it's funny but it's
got an emotional quality and tone to it
yeah the song that we closed the show
out with and you knew this most people
probably didn't pick up on the fact that
I like flub to lyrics I mean we ended up
like just changing in the moment one
lyric that was from a different part of
the song and then there was one part
where I didn't come in but you sing that
part whatever which by this point in
there and the tour wasn't typical we're
actually that song and I told you later
I was like I was so in the moment and
and thinking that like I cannot believe
how much fun this is I cannot believe
how good this is you know I'm saying not
good like I can't believe how good we
are just how good this is all lining up
yeah you were savoring it man I think
that's great and I lost the ability to
be to be in a song because I was so in
the moment it's like I kind of left my
body for a second and took a little
flight around the Ryman and communed
with the spirits of old country
and then came back in to my body was
like oh I should be seeing ya it was
magical man I I mean it was it the peak
of our career yeah I mean it hasn't
gotten any better than that for me
personally well it was two days ago
no I'm saying in people are like what's
the best moment in your career oh wow I
can't think of any time where I felt as
fulfilled and what we get to do right is
in that moment but because the other
things that I mean you put out the
internet video and it's this like you
can only be so fulfilled by like the
response to the comments I mean and you
can if you make if you craft a
documentary or a series or anything and
you like screen it and then people
you're like watching people from the
back of the room and then they're
clapping it's like that is very
thrilling but it's not the same as
performing I mean as having that moment
of all the faces are staring back at you
and you're like I'm savoring this like
the like the first bite of hot chicken I
ever had yeah you know you never have I
mean you can read about hot chicken you
can make analogies about hot chicken at
the end of podcasts right but until you
eat the hot chicken on the stage of the
Ryman mm-hmm shoot that would have been
peak that's that would have been too
much sensory overload that's gonna be
our next tour I mean that's what people
want am i right into her yeah we're just
gonna get on stage and eat hot chicken
well and that's another thing I'm glad
you brought that up
not the hot chicken but the eating thing
because you know me and we've talked
about this before it's like another
reason that it's so fulfilling to me
it's like okay it's cool when we like
it's like oh we got to there's 15
million people subscribe to good
mythical morning and that's awesome
and it's and you know what it's why
people show up at our freakin show dude
so let's be honest it's why people can
show
watch us sing they're not sure they're
not showing up to watch us sing
primarily most people because they've
seen a sing they seen as do weird stuff
on the internet they want to come hang
out with us but because I truly believe
that we you know we crafted something
like we have crafted a show that I feel
good about artistically and creatively
and again that's the thing that kind of
gets me going
right it's obviously I love the stuff
that's not planned in the humor that
happens in the moment in the things that
make that particular show unique but the
thing that really gets me going is like
sitting down and over the course of a
like labored process creating something
special that then is crafted with the
real-time reception of an audience in
mind you know what I'm saying yeah and
in the end it's very rewarding and then
being able together to go out there and
actually execute it and see the
real-time feel the real-time reaction
from an audience in a place that's so
special the combination of those things
in the way that it came together I was
just like it doesn't get any better than
this I mean like we could hopefully
we'll continue to do great things
hopefully we've got bigger and better
things ahead of us and there's other
creative things that we want to do but
regardless of how well those things go
and how well they're received it can
only match in my mind it can only match
the way I felt at the Ryman yeah yeah I
feel that way too I'm just in it again
going out there and doing a show it puts
everything else we've done in
perspective because we wouldn't be able
to do it if it weren't for the other
things but I'm grateful for the
experience because of everything you
said and also because it it just put it
it gives us perspective that we can't
have when we just sit behind our desk
yeah yeah and like we say we say at the
shows you know it's like there's with
all kinds of amazing things that have
all the the interactions that we have
with people online
are invaluable and amazing in in volume
much greater you know there's just way
more of them because it's the nature of
the Internet but there is just something
different about being in a room full of
mythical beasts it's like we just don't
get to experience that like we make this
podcast we do the show we do there's
other things and people experience it on
this regular basis and have these
special connections and then we hear
about them retrospectively and that's
really special but to be in the same
room while it's all happening in the
immediate feedback and I feel like it's
we've got a very first of all our
audiences is very eclectic in a lot of
ways in terms of like just where people
are from their background their ages but
there's there's also something very
uniform about the way the people who are
just mythical you know I'm saying and so
there's a lot of like-minded people in
the same room who are just like
connecting you know not just with us but
with each other being in that in that
atmosphere is just special yeah so again
I want to thank you for if you've come
out to one of our shows thank you and I
invite invite you if you haven't it's
checkout rhettandlink live all of this
isn't a promotion for us I mean it's an
inadvertent promotion that's why I'm
just gonna I'll plug it again red link
live.com I'm also I got Jenna to record
our sound check for the merle cover with
britain i have that so i'm gonna post
that on this society let me get that
post another society so that wasn't
that's the sound check not from the
Reimann but from DC because we didn't
have a lot of time to check at the Ryman
so we had to practice it was good
because we were still learning it hey no
matter how put I'll post it there on on
the Society for okay so if it doesn't
sound good it's just a little treat okay
I got anything else that we want to say
before I give me a wreck man give us a
wreck okay your turn I'm gonna give a
wreck this is one of those things that
many many months behind when everyone
was talking about this thing but if
you're like me you didn't see it
originally and I I watched this movie on
the plane and so I'm gonna do a wreck of
bow Burnham's eighth grade for those of
you who have not taken the time to see
this movie I just highly recommend it
it's just there's something about it
that's this is so visceral like the the
way that he puts you into the experience
of middle school in a way that makes you
feel uncomfortable and I don't ever feel
that way when I watch stuff you know I'm
saying it's like people talk about I
can't watch that because it makes me
feel uncomfortable you know and I wasn't
about to stop watching it but he's so
effective and the lead actor in this
whatever name is something Fisher what
her name is
no I don't know where her name is look
that up because I want to get that right
the the lead actor the lead actress and
uh in eighth grade the way that she's
incredible she just nails it so hard and
so it's just really cool to see somebody
that we knew from way back
you know we hung out with Bo Burnham at
YouTube live back in 2008 seven probably
eight and he was just a youtuber man and
he goes off and writes and directs this
incredible film so I know many of you
have probably seen it but a lot of you
are probably more of you are like me and
you just didn't watch it the first time
it came out I just highly recommend it
what's her name Elsie Fisher Elsie
Fisher all right thanks for that right
it's gonna go on and do a even bigger
things all right guys thanks for hanging
out with us and
will speak at you again next week we'll
give you another biscuit for your ears
yeah maybe next week will be the peak of
our careers to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]